now shifting gears we're now a year into
the special councils probe and Bob
Muller apparently has another target
Reuters reporting he subpoenaed Roger
stones former social media specialist
Jason Sullivan to appear before a grand
jury tomorrow
Muller is reportedly interested in
whether the Trump campaign was in any
way involved in the WikiLeaks release of
those DNC emails during the 2018 20 2016
of course presidential campaign now
stone is a longtime confidant a
President Trump and the author of the
new book love it
stones Rules how to win it politics
business and style can I get the style
front from you Roger that's all and now
he joins us exclusively it's great to
see how are you doing Roger great to be
here Congrats on the book we have some
rules we pulled out but tell me what's
your reaction to now we're now into year
two of this investigation officially
today and they're bringing in the guy
who worked for you on Twitter and social
media trending what's going on there
well at this point I don't know if I'm a
person of interest or just an
interesting person it's very clear that
not only has mr. Muller subpoenaed a
part-time consultant who worked for me
for three months he's also dropped
subpoenas on a number of other young
people who work for me in all honesty I
think this is driven by a fake news
narrative that insists that I must have
known in advance about the hacking of
the DNC which I dispute ever really
happened by the Russians I don't think
it happened at all never mind by the
Russians and I must have had advance
notice of the content the source and the
exact disclosure time of the WikiLeaks
DNC disclosures that is of course false
but it is not pleasant to have a special
prosecutor with unbridled power in your
emails in your text messages in your
phone calls and he's very clearly in
mind
it's an enormous invasion a violation of
my Fourth Amendment rights and there's
no probable cause here Julian Assange
himself has said Roger stone never said
anything on Twitter that he didn't glean
by simply following what I was saying in
interviews and in my own Twitter feed
now they're hanging this all on that
tweet that you road hog esteem where you
said trust me it'll soon be too
Podesta's time in the barrel and hashtag
crooked Hillary I know you like Celine
that's amore that's a misquote if what I
said was it will soon be the Podesta's
time in the barrel referring to two
people now people called Donald from the
Donald but no one ever called John
Podesta the Podesta I'm referring to
John and Tony because in April of 2016
they're Shady Russian business deals
were exposed in the Panama papers as a
student of opposition research I was
well aware of that
I never predicted the hacking or theft
of John Podesta Z mails I said the
Podesta's but that is conveniently
omitted from virtually every media
report and it's even omitted from the
House Intelligence Committee final
report my lawyers had to write a letter
asking for a correction the Podesta's
clearly refers to two people John and
Tony now your old friend Adam Schiff he
says and complains that you deny
everything
and so you need subpoenas for your
tweets and your direct Twitter messages
you said this what we ought to do if
we're doing a credible investigation is
subpoena Twitter for direct messages
that went to these particular handles or
that came from Roger stone so that we
don't have to accept and rely upon the
word of Roger stone which i think is a
hazardous thing to do you know one thing
that Roger stone and the president have
in common is a philosophy that you deny
everything know that only suckers and
losers admit to anything if you deny it
it didn't happen well Laura first of all
I testified fully and truthfully to the
House Intelligence Committee and I
turned over to them the WikiLeaks and
gusoff er direct message exchanges which
are innocuous that one get in touch with
the gusta 42.0 simply by going to direct
messages but here's the point based on
the content the context and the timing
of that exchange it's six
weeks after WikiLeaks has already
published the DNC disclosures
consequently chronologically collusion
in the hacking of that material is
impossible there entirely ex post facto
they're benign and I turn them over to
the committee so Intel has it house
Intel committee has the Senate
Intelligence Committee will have it
because I'm cooperating with you and you
wanted to testify in public yes they
brought you behind closed doors why is
that
well now the House Democrats complained
that my testimony is not public when
they're the ones who wanted to be in
private let me say this I have agreed to
cooperate with the Senate Judiciary and
Intelligence Committee
I would like my testimony to be in
public I'm going to turn over these
exact same documents and they are
complete George Stephanopoulos had
Michael Caputo on your old colleague was
how it went down Michael Caputo who
worked on the campaign just met with
Muller's team this week he came out
saying they asked a lot of questions
about collusion he came away quite
concerned about Paul Manafort Roger
stone Rick gates and others I was
recounting what Caputo had said that is
they're very concerned about manna fort
stone gates and others well it's very
interesting CNBC and MSNBC and that
partisan hack r-remember who tries to
pose as a journalist keep insisting that
Muller is focusing on my long
relationship with Rick gates I didn't
meet Rick gates until 2016 I've never
been alone with him they're focused on
dinners there's one dinner Michael
Caputo is there John Haggerty from the
Trump campaign is there Steve mouths
Berg from Newsmax is there and manna
fort is supposed to join us but at the
last minute gates shows up in his stead
showing up late and leaving early
there's no discussion of WikiLeaks or
Julian Assange this is the only dinner
I've never been out with mr. gates and
no we did not work together at Black
Manta Ford stone thirty years ago he was
not there that is a falsehood
what about this Sam Nunn burg comment
that he made you know he's been she
showed up when some shows seems to be a
little inebriated at one point but this
was also back in March going back to
what
you said about julian assange let's
watch the minute he told me on the phone
that he had met with Assange i assumed
he was lying it's something roger does
it's one of the stone rules it's a
tactic it's a trump tactic to take
credit insinuate yourself when you say
it's something he does you mean Roger
stone lies to people like you his mentee
yeah well exactly I call puffery
exaggeration
I call it bluffing and posturing look
when you work with sam nunn berg
sometimes he would call you 20 30 40
times a day and when you take his call
he'd say stop stalking what's going on
30 times a day whoa
one Friday late in the afternoon when I
wanted to get him off the phone my wife
told me dinner was ready and Sam kept
saying and one more thing one more thing
he said do you have any plans for the
weekend I said yeah I'm gonna fly to
London and have dinner with Julie and
massage its stick it's a throwaway line
it's a joke so what is like why don't we
talk about the angle or things taken out
of context right then they're isolated
then they're blasted out well then when
they're used to smear people that's the
art of a smear when I figured out he
believed it I milked the joke in an
email but I produced airline records I
produced credit card records that prove
I was in Los Angeles
I even produced a receipt from Izzy's
deli on Santa Monica that proves that I
was in LA and obviously Laura my
passport customs records air lock never
been to Russia
you've never ordered a White Russian
that I was not in that I was not in
London and I've never met with or spoken
with Julianne sob I the way stones rules
from your book yes I love okay here's my
favorite part of stones real stones
rules hit from every angle open multiple
fronts on your enemy the enemy must be
confused and feel besieged yes I'm on
every side it seems like that's what
they're doing to Donald Trump well
they're certainly trying to look
everything the president needs to do to
search for his presidency served to
survive is in this book I would direct
him to this on this rule attack attack
attack don't defend I love it when he
calls out the free the fake news media I
love it when he exposes what is the
greatest political scandal in
American history the use of a phony
dossier to rationalize the surveillance
by the state using the power and the
authority in the state to spy on the
Republican candidate for president
it's like Sun Tzu's Art of War it's like
sunsoo Roger stones art of war and
there's so there's a little crossover a
Venn diagram there I like